hello freak [ __ ] but hey I did want
to ask something so when you're growing
up was there pressure because your dad
is Clint Eastwood
did you and then you said you wanted to
be an actor you knew was that yeah we're
going back to it but yeah it's a good
good question well I think I think I
always wanted to be a tell stories I
don't know if I necessarily knew I want
to be an actor hmm
I think as I get older I realized it's
more about telling stories I just sort
of fell into the acting okay well this
could be a way I could get in I could I
could go in to just enjoy entertainment
process like creating something that
you're entertained by and enjoy yeah
exactly telling a story you know people
can relate to laugh cry whatever do you
think you'll go the route of your dad
and like maybe do some directing and
writing things along yeah zip slam
that's a plan that's the plan you know
it taking control of your own career is
good and also you know you tell the
stories you want to tell if we were
talking about this before the podcast
that the world of the actor is very
difficult and a lot of people like
accuse actors of being fake and I think
one of the reasons for the autistic yeah
this is that for sure but one of the
reasons for the accusing them of being
fake is that they always have to put on
the best show like as far as their
behavior and the way they act and think
in their opinions because they're
constantly trying to get cast in things
and it's all about getting people to
like you and politicking and and we were
talking also about like you kind of have
to have liberal sensibilities like in
this town if you if you're a right go
together
does that even make sense it seems like
they contradicted liberal sensibilities
as well it's one reason that I moved I
moved at LA is you know years ago I just
I got sick of either are great they're
great people in LA
young people and you know I'm I'm from
California so I feel have a you know as
a place in my heart here but I got an LA
because you know you meet a hundred
people in LA you might be in 95 that are
full of [ __ ] and you know five good ones
and and I could get generous
oh that yes a problem everyone always
always always judge it when when I meet
somebody and I'm having a conversation
with them and I ask how they're doing
you know I mean an actor or something
how you been oh we canonical and you a
lot of times they're just there's a
waiting for their turn to talk
you're not even listening to you yeah
they're just sort of you know did you
know they're not going to return that
and say how what are you doing what you
know what's going yeah you don't feel
like it's sincere conversation oh no not
at all
yeah that's a big issue people in
general but in LA it's I think this is
the the magnet for all the narcissists
and all the people that want attention
and the people that that have a hole
they have a hole they need to fill up
for whatever their childhood whatever
whatever luck it is and they gravitate
here and then they just communicate with
each other the same way and everybody
kind of like pretends to be someone who
they're not
and then hopefully they make it and then
once they make it then they just you
know become some [ __ ] weirdo just
it's it's weird how many of them are
like almost like cookie cutter like oh
I've met that guy before he just look
different you know yeah I mean it's like
it's like the same person live in a
different life I've noticed I know the
way to the other assembly line yeah
people yeah if they fell asleep or
something but the actor world is like
I've met a lot of comedians that are
similar but they're a lot to vary so
much but the actors boy there's a lot
that are super similar just a lot of you
know but then again you'll meet some of
them who've like figured it out and made
it through and they're super normal and
really like Adam Sandler is one of the
nicest guys you've ever met you lightly
oh my god couldn't be nicer totally give
you didn't know he was out in Sandler
and you met him you'd be like God
someone's dad [ __ ] super normal dude
yeah Tom Hanks you're red you said super
normal that's what people say you know
like because they asked me Oh how's
Scott you know seems normal
so that's why that's what you're like so
you must not know me yet for next yeah
it is because an actor is like this well
I don't know yeah Who am I to say who's
normal right right me seems like a
normal guy and you said Adam Sandler is
completely normal so that kind of puts
in perspective yeah why me my normal is
like you could talk to them and they're
really there they're real sincere yeah
you get the present but they're having a
real conversation wouldn't you and
there's a lot of people that just don't
do that you talk to them and they're
just putting on some hey how are you
yeah see you I definitely don't trust
people who are too nice I'm like why are
they so nice this isn't right yeah it's
just a tough world for these people
anyway especially the ones that haven't
made it out here so psychologically
devastating because you're constantly
going on auditions and you're constantly
getting rejected so you're insecure in
the first place and then you are hoping
someone likes you so you go to this
thing and and and you're kind of like
putting on your best behavior you're
dressing good like I put it pleased to
meet you a nice all right all right hey
hey thanks guys thanks for the
opportunity we've I like you like you
stay said you sucked at the audition but
I didn't [ __ ] no they just really didn't
like you they said you didn't make eye
contact [ __ ] yeah you know and people
get weirder and weirder and if you meet
an actor say like like one year and then
you meet them ten years later and
they're still swinging and nothing's
happening they might be like almost
ready to crack yeah like the threat of
birds right at that falling down with
that Michael Douglas you know when he's
[ __ ] he's got the briefcase and he
goes in traffic starts shooting people
yeah I feel like a couple of days before
they're like right on the operating and
take it anymore
it's a [ __ ] devastating business
right it's tough it's tough but you know
it like I said we were talking about
before it's it's all it's all built on
hard work and your reputation yeah
because like you say you know and you
get a reputation for being an [ __ ] or
you know showing up late to work or just
down the other and you know everyone's
going to know about it it's a small
place LA so being a diva
you know diva diva that's a big one
right it's not a good
that's not a good active can't shake
that one yeah that happens to people
like in Hollywood they'll they'll be
doing a lot of big movies and you hear
like oh she's difficult to work with
yeah and they just [ __ ] disappear
sure wish and it's almost seems like
Hollywood delights and shut it all out
that they're written for you to fail
yeah they got a but one you proved to be
like ungrateful
in some way or you don't like here's a
perfect example well he kind of made it
on television were David Caruso when
David Caruso was on NYPD Blue and what
he's like wow this guy's a great actor
and then he quit NYPD Blue and it was
this massive hit show and then went and
started doing like some real shitty
movies yeah everybody was like wild [ __ ]
would you quit a big show like NYPD Blue
and do a bunch of movies like oh I hope
he fails and the movies failed and then
everybody like hey and then and then he
never did a movie again you never saw in
a good movie like he like had this
trajectory of this amazing career yeah
Danny became this caricature because
then he was doing that stupid cop show
where would take his glasses off and say
some stupid pun well it looks like he
got nailed
he took his laptop remember that it was
like CSI Miami or something like that
and it was a [ __ ] caricature of a cop
show yeah
whereas NYPD Blue when he was on it was
groundbreaking I mean it was [ __ ]
fantastic so what happened it just he
became and I don't know well know who
yet deva is that we recognize as a diva
whether i was actually a dealer i don't
know the guy you'd have to meet him and
talk to him a little bit but he had that
stink and you get that sticker that's
death the other thing too is it's not
even you know in Hollywood it's not even
what's true sometimes just where I
sieved it so it's it you know my daddy's
always saying you say believe half of
what you see and none of what you hear
and and then I always stuck with me
because you know you sit down with
people in the industry or whatever and
you just hear you know a lot of
Hollywood is a gossip risible gossip
queen everybody wants to talk [ __ ] about
someone they worked with or tell some
story tell how difficult somebody was at
this matter and you don't even you know
it's a business built on you know it's
just a house of cards you know you're
like well that how do you even know that
that's even true right you know is so it
kind of [ __ ] up it's you know I mean
obviously like that happens in other
businesses but maybe it does with color
how maybe it does it's also there's it's
a weird thing because when you're a
movie star like yourself
and you're on the screen like you get
all
all the adulation and all the love
there's a whole crew of people behind
you yeah the special effects people and
lighting and sound and directors and
game user as a game then young jamie is
a hundred people to everyone that's on
the screen right and so and they get no
love Yeah right
they can note you know they get no 11
and that's where the business side of
the business is so delusion because here
the agents and the people around us
they're not the one they're you know
putting in this the sweat every day for
five months to make a film you know
pulling the creative ideas pulling the
hard work you know the grips and all the
other guys who you know are underpaid
and are you know working just to make
money to you know feed their families so
it's it's interesting because I saw it
from a very different lens I saw it from
my father's lens which is you know my
dad show up on time get the movie done
shoot it fast treat everybody good and
and you work with the same people over
and over again you do the right thing by
people have integrity where it people
don't see that side of the business
there's so much other stuff that you
know the people never get love for and
in the film industry
yeah well in the long hour so that's
another thing that people don't
understand if you're on a film set like
what's an average day for you oh it
could be I mean a short days a 12-hour
day so it's you know 12 to 16 and how
many days a week you work in five six I
mean when you're on location
you're usually you could be in a movie
that's doing a six-day Work Week or you
could be doing five eight but by the end
everyone's doing a six sometimes even
you know you're just putting in full
you're a full-throttle
to get the movie done now when you're on
location do you have to squeeze a
workout in to keep your brain same yeah
how do you do that on a 16-hour day I
try to do it during lunch because I find
that if you go to lunch you you get
sluggish after lunch right and then you
go in I'll [ __ ] I got to get back in
there you know and do this I got to hit
the coffee or get it to whatever
when I get stimulated okay right yeah
that's what you're saying yeah just just
about you
a mascara okay but just a bump and get
the head a little bit
whoo but yet so I think working out
during lunch seems to be the best thing
for me because I don't do well in the
mornings for a workout because I feel
stiff mm-hmm so I like to get the blood
going first if I can hit it during lunch
even if I'm on set I'll do what it is
done both this and the other and then
I'll have I'll get you know some
endorphins kick in
[Applause]
[Music]